european union home affairs ministers
will discuss
this week better ways to prevent
accidents in the mediterranean sea
as would-be asylum seekers head for
europe's shores
in poorly maintained boats the ministers
will examine what steps they can take in
the short term
to help avoid tragedies like the one off
the italian island of lampedusa
debate will be based on a report by the
task force for the mediterranean
which has identified priority actions
that should be taken
the tragedies at sea will be a focus
when european leaders meet in brussels
in june
ministers will also discuss the problem
of foreign fighters from europe
crossing the border into syria to fight
and the security threat they could pose
in the eu when they return
the flow of foreign fighters traveling
to syria from the eu and other countries
has not diminished
on the contrary numbers seem to be on
the rise
the ministers will examine proposals to
dissuade them from leaving and more
efficient use of eu instruments for
information exchange and judicial
cooperation
they'll also look at how the eu can
boost its engagement with other
countries like syria's neighbors
through the exchange of best practices
and capacity building assistance
data protection is a key issue for
justice ministers
they'll discuss new ways to better
protect personal information
notably the so-called one-stop shop
principle
the council will also address the issue
of fully applying provisions of the
schengen passport-free
area in bulgaria and romania